[Musique]
c'est
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
voilà ce soir
merci d'accueillir le champion tony
[Musique]
dominique elle tombait c'est une grande
gueule sache que tu auras des victoires
contre 1 dans les classes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la publicité n'a comme la princesse l
arrivée au pavillon
la river il arrivait en en revanche
c'est parfois ligne il est reparti
alors
[Musique]
je savais que c'est la grande finale de
ping pong s'est moqué c'est moi qui ai
gagné deux derniers matches vous
rappelle que ces derniers cas gagner le
championnat je vous le dis j'ai battu
djokovic locaux vides numéro un mondial
des voitures qui m'ont fait pleurer
comme un petit chien est arrivé de merde
si j'ose dire alors que les poings
serrés ils sont souvent sur des fautes
directes mer
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
m
et
waouh
[Applaudissements]